Welcome to AB testing podcast, your modern testing podcast.
Your hosts, Alan and Brent will be here to guide you through topics on testing, leadership,
agile and anything else that comes to mind.
Now on with the show.
I thought I'd just be quiet at the beginning and see if Brent said anything.
I was ready.
I know.
Hey everyone.
Welcome to the ABC testing podcast.
Our special guest chat GPT is not attending today.
Um, maybe next time, maybe next time, but always for there for inspiration.
I was surprised someone actually grabbed one of my quotes out of the podcast and tweeted
it something about your chat GPT is my collaborator, which it is my friend.
Unfortunately in my life and where I'm at in the world and post pandemic chat GPT is
likely my best friend.
And you can take that to be just about as sad as it sounds.
I got a couple of things.
Maybe before we get into that, um, is there anything new, exciting?
Oh, let's talk about in terms of, in terms of friends, are you still employed?
I am still employed.
Awesome.
Um, I will say that one thing that's interesting on that one, uh, not surprising to you
in some regards to GPT is a great ally friend to, to data scientists and everyone around
the world.
Uh, but if you are running a data science team and you specialize in NLP, GPT also represents
a great threat to your value proposition.
I always be prepared to find a new value proposition.
Nobody's.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I mean, I've been hearing about jobs going away due to computer programs, whether it's
automation or AI for as long as I've been in tech, yet people seem, most people seem to
remain deployed and move and shift as needed.
The thing I'm doing right now, I'm kind of dumb with AI.
I'm kidding, but I'm speaking on behalf of our listeners.
It's going to move hot and fast, right?
Our listeners, you should expect to hear about it for a while because things are, are still
going very hot and fast.
But for me, I kind of treat this very similarly to how I did, how I treated it when we made
the last transition and probably the one before that.
No.
So I kind of think of it very similarly to, to discussions we knew and I had when it
was very clear to both you and I, right?
That no, like the metaphor I use is, is test is like a chicken that just got its head cut
off.
From afar, it doesn't look dead, but it's dead.
Right.
We, we saw, we noticed that the momentum is now unstoppable.
Test is going away at Microsoft.
We both predicted this very accurately.
I don't remember your situation in particular, but I do know that.
That was fine.
No, I mean, in terms of, so I predicted it and I remember predicting it and saying, oh
yeah, it's absolutely going to happen in the next three years.
Welcome to episode 23 of the AB testing podcast.
Right.
I was wrong on that.
I mean, my prediction was correct.
Not that much.
But it happened in one year, not three.
Yeah.
And, and I'm kind of feeling the same thing right now.
So very similar to what I did in test as I started investing myself and my team in a direction
where we are still strong, but doesn't try to live in a world where GPT doesn't succeed
in mastering NLP.
Let me, I don't, I don't want to have this conversation yet again.
I will talk about the metaphor and it, it is very similar.
And what happened when companies moved away from having dedicated testers and were very
successful on it is that those that.
Grasped on to the moving car when I'm, my metaphors are going out the window here,
but those who survived and did very well and thrived in that change were the ones who
embraced the change and figure out, okay, we're trying to move faster.
I'm going to figure out how to help the team move faster, accelerate the achievement,
shippable quality, the people who are just, just, I just want to do algorithms all day
and blah, blah, blah.
It's really kind of a fixed mindset, right?
Same with the old testers fixed mindset, digging their heels in.
I do one thing.
I do one thing only.
If you embrace it, if you use AI to enhance what you do and what you do is an AI,
you bring value to the team using ML and AI tools.
You can still do that in a different way using some of these tools to help you
embrace it, lean in, have an open mind, and you'll be successful.
And this is true across any one of 50,000 different similar transitions.
People, I mean, you can go back in business magazines back to the fifties
and you'll find people saying, ooh, business automation is going to get rid of
the need for blah.
And it did kind of, but what it did was it enabled people to do really cool things.
I remember back in 1997 or so, driving to work, listening to KISW before it
turned into a crappy station and someone called in and was like, hey, I'm working
it wherever and we have some mechanical machines coming in.
I'm going to take my job away.
I heard that and I heard, yeah, you can look at it like that.
Yeah, I was going to take my job away.
What's really going to happen is that it's going to give you time to do
something more interesting than moving part A from shelf A to shelf B all day
long. So anyway, let's talk about something far, far more interesting.
Okay.
Let's talk about me.
I just kidding.
I thought it was a good transition.
I'm going to go back and forth between old job and new job a little bit.
I already have people on, I should get to my new gig, my NBC Universal gig here
in a second, not go too deep into it, but I already have people, including my
boss. Well, I'm not sure what's worse.
Brent interrupting me with the NBC chimes or Brent talking with his hands
completely covering his mouth.
I'll let you all figure it out.
So many people, including my boss, listen to the podcast.
Got to be careful what I say.
My boss is on your new team.
Yeah. And don't and Steve, turn the mic off.
He just a raging idiot.
I'm kidding.
He's actually really good.
I should, I should drop a link to his blog sometime, which I'm on the podcast
sometime now. Now I was going to give him an idea.
Oh God. Anyway, but before you get there, so Steve,
Steve open invite anytime you are welcome on the podcast.
So unfortunately I read in the news this week and then a bunch of people
reached out to me.
Actually I saw, I found out about it.
Unity did its third round of layoffs in a year.
So they had cut from about 8,000 now down to about 7,000 employees in a year.
Do some math, figure out that, or that percentages it's a, it's 12.5% whatever.
And so that's tough.
And all the management books tell you everything you study says,
you got to do the, if you have to do layoffs and there's lots of studies
that say layoffs don't even do much for the bottom line, but do one deep cut.
These three semi deep shallow cuts is, is really rough on my routes.
I feel really bad for my old employees, but then they did a thing I kind of want
to talk about a little bit and that one of the things that, okay,
here's a weird thing.
When I decided I was ready to look for a new job,
I was ready for it to be a six month, the 12 month search.
Cause I wanted to be picky and there was a bunch of things I wanted.
I wanted a manager. I liked, yes, Steve, I like you.
I wanted to people I liked working with Steve, please don't tell the people on the
team. I like working with them and I'm ready for that yet. And then three,
I wanted a product that I'm interested in.
And the cool thing working at NBC universal is I get a chance to learn really
a whole new technology, not in the, in the stack or the stack site enough.
Yeah. But I get a chance to learn a little bit more how broadcast media
works, just kind of interesting. By the way,
I was in Los Angeles for a couple of days this week.
Steve took me on a golf cart trip around the back loss of NBC universal.
I drove through the set of the good place and wisteria lane,
we're just for housewives was and saw that we're the Bates hotel from psycho.
Lots of cool stuff. Anyway, rewind the stack. And I wanted after working at a
globally distributed company and many, many time zones of work and sometimes
doing two of the same meeting in a day, which I didn't mind it.
I liked it. I like engaging with the team,
but it was starting to burn me out.
We talked about that a few times ago.
The other thing I wanted was I was getting beginning to get some push to go
back to the office at unity. They wanted to go, well,
let's get the leaders to go in three times a week. And I remember our,
well, so they use his name. I won't use his name. A,
a people leader at unity who I don't have a lot of respect for due to
previous, the previous interactions with him to unity came into the office.
One day, first time I'd ever seen him in the office to ask us if we'd,
he might've been even been on zoom to ask the leaders in the Seattle office.
If we start going in three times a week. And I told him,
I've been coming in three times a week out of me being a little sick of home
for a long time and hasn't made a difference. I don't think this is going to
happen.
Gave all kinds of feedback on how none of the teams were in one spot and
blah, blah, blah. And it was just weird.
And that was some part of what I wanted to do when I joined a company was join a
team that was largely or fully remote and our engineering team,
although some people go to offices, if they're near one,
it is basically fully remote, which is no,
there's no requirement to go to the office. It means I get to work.
The times when I have a meeting,
when there's that weird hybrid thing,
when you have all your little zoom or teams windows,
let's come back to that too. And you have person, person, person,
whole group of people is really, really rare. It's generally,
I've maybe seen it once. So it's one person. So anyway, that's really cool.
So all those things just kind of came together very quickly when NBCU contacted
me. I got all the three P's of people, the person, the product.
I got some of the, the sort of intangibles I wanted around fully remote work.
And it all kind of worked out much quicker than I had planned.
And here I am a couple of things to drill in along the road.
There is, oh,
the reason I brought up unity is not only the layoff 600 people,
but in the same swipe of the knife,
they said that everyone at the company, this is heck, this is hurt.
I haven't heard it from unity leadership. I've heard it from people reaching out
going, Hey, this sucks.
What do you think is that they're requiring people to go to the office three
days a week from now on, actually starting at some date in the near future,
which I think I'm curious to hear your opinion on this,
maybe compared to Microsoft, but I think I'm, I was going to say horrible.
I think it's kind of idiotic unless they're trying to get people to quit.
What Microsoft is still full.
Can you, you can still be fully remote at Microsoft. Is that correct?
Oh yeah. It's, I would say right now,
Microsoft is going in the opposite direction of that.
The, um,
please don't come in. It's cheaper for us when you work at home, right?
Well, they're never, they're, they're not going to mention it that way.
Right. I, my career, I, I,
I fill in the parts that people say quietly. I say the quiet parts out loud.
What is happening is certainly we,
it's it's public that Microsoft is not renewing the lease on any of its
lease buildings. Correct. Right. So that's public.
What we can also see is there is a,
there is a large sentence. Like I can look, as you know,
I come into my office every day and I have been doing so for the last several
years, all but one month of COVID and parking lots empty.
And so there's some rationale to,
to Microsoft being able to do that. Yeah, of course.
I would say Microsoft could look at,
they could turn into a lease or at least some of their buildings to other people
at some point. I'm not sure the security implications around that,
but that could be done. I think across the campus,
my gut is that there are buildings,
a whole bunch of buildings, no more than a quarter full.
For sure. I,
I would be surprised if there's any building that's a quarter full.
Yeah. The one thing though, team cohesion,
I would say certainly I haven't discovered the secret to it.
I do miss team cohesion. I miss the work benefits.
I miss the personal benefits of having the team there and working together.
Do you remember once upon a time when I asked you like a question,
a yes or no question of does Microsoft require people to go back to work?
So the answer is no. It doesn't, no. And here's the deal. I think,
you know, I don't know what's inside of you news executives minds. Uh,
but there is, I get where they're coming from a little bit.
There's something that you get when people are together that you don't,
that many teams don't generally get when they're all in their homes.
My goal, what drives me and what I'm,
I think I'm making some progress on it.
What I'm always thinking of as a manager is how do I do that?
How do I build team cohesion?
How do I get a team to work together when they're not all hanging out one place?
I think what has happened over the last,
has it been 25 years since COVID hit? I can't quite remember.
I've lost track of time. So in the last, uh, three or 25 years is that we have
meetings and maybe even more meetings,
which is odd because there's two things we screwed up on.
One is in our meetings, all we ever talk about is work.
I shouldn't say we as too big of a generalization.
If you don't change anything,
you have zoom meetings or teams meetings and all we ever talk about is work.
We never get fun or can we just talk about stuff? Can we goof off together?
So one thing to do is make it,
we had a discussion in the Slack group this week about the same thing.
What do you do about remote teams? One of the three.slack.com,
you can go to moderntesting.org and get a link.
I will try and keep it up to date. It's not up to date.
You can yell at me, but don't always talk about meetings.
There's things like take the first five minutes of every meeting just for people
to either show up late or just have hallway talk, whatever,
but also is focused on async work.
Not every decision needs a meeting.
Not every design needs a meeting.
Collaborate as much as you can asynchronously and just embrace,
like embrace the fact that we're not all getting back together and focus more
on it. So where many organizations I feel have failed here is giving managers
and teams the education because they don't know it's all right.
And there's so little experimenting because they're driving people to get stuff
done to get, uh,
give people a chance of being successful in a fully remote world.
I think a lot of times people haven't done that.
So if the managers to figure it out,
the managers don't try to figure it out.
If they don't think it's their job to figure it out,
it can get really boring really fast.
The issue as I see it,
I do wish my team would come in more often in terms of,
of the, the requirements.
So why don't you require them to come to work three days a week?
Yeah. But then that's not going to work.
That's a real question. Tell me why it doesn't work.
I understand the rationale around unity making the decision, right?
The benefit they're trying to achieve. Unfortunately, uh, and I,
and I know you agree with this.
The way they approached it is going to guarantee they don't achieve the
benefits they were seeking.
Yeah, it's unfortunate.
Right. It's no, you have to,
if you want that the benefits of that you get from the team being co-located,
you either have to completely pull the sweat, right?
Very similar to what you were just saying before, right?
You basically do an Elon Musk type of thing and you're like, Hey,
from here on out, everyone is required back at work every day.
Right. And then yeah,
you're going to go through a difficult period and then people will renormalize or
you have to create, you have to make,
you have to create a motivation or an incentive such that it's their choice and
they would prefer. Yeah. Carrots versus sticks.
Exactly. If you're going to do a stick, the stick has to be,
has to be, has to hit hard and fast and then be over very similar to the
layoff situation. But if you're not, then it's got to be in the carrot.
Although I would prefer a cupcake carrot suck.
So one thing I put a pin in, I want to talk about.
So I have a whole bunch of stuff about work we could talk about,
but let's see, you know, we used to do this session like Alan at Unity.
What have you learned? We'll do a little bit here in a moment.
But one thing I got to tell you, so remember,
it's such a different situation from when I left Microsoft to Microsoft.
I was on this really toxic team, so I was really bitter about it.
And I give you a bad time about it a lot, but you told me Satya is making it
better. And I actually do believe you decide to be giving you a bad time.
I wasn't going to use and I still haven't used the Bing chat thing you suggest
to me, but I didn't use it because I don't run windows because who does.
And but I found out they make edge for Mac because the Bing chat thing only
works on edge. So I'm going to try that out sometime.
I heard from one of my new directs that edge on Mac isn't so bad,
so I'll give it a shot. So the difference is that Unity is like,
my team was fricking awesome. I really, you know, it's a bunch of people.
I still really miss and I'm it's unfortunate in that situation.
Any of my anger at Unity is towards our executive leadership.
Just good people. It's just in some unfortunate circumstances.
But as I've mentioned on this podcast before,
other than visual studio code and my Xbox,
I did not use a Microsoft application from the day I left Microsoft it during
my entire run at Unity. And I'm very happy about that.
I didn't really miss it. So here I am working at NBCU and damn it,
if they don't use Microsoft apps,
I spend a chunk of my day on teams calls now and it's not so bad.
What the, what are you doing?
Brent is looking at me as tongues like, okay, so, uh,
okay teams, it's all right. It's all right. It's a little flakier.
Like sometimes when my camera dies, it's a little flakier,
but they're doing okay there. I'm not, it's, it's better.
I think they've replaced all the leadership on teams since I left probably at least
once. So it's doing all right. Uh,
the other thing is office apps.
They just feel cluttered to me.
Like you've been, you've been used to the Google version.
Yeah. And so they do and they don't.
So the apps feel cluttered. I spent, oh my God,
how much time trying to use PowerPoint the other day and it hurt.
I'm going to go back to keynote. Uh, I can't do it again.
Just trying to find where commands were and looking up things on the web.
It's just, I think to me, PowerPoint is just awful.
Word I kind of like Excel's, you know, good. Um,
I don't use most of the features of it and, and, but it's, it's,
I can handle it. Outlook on Mac is lacking.
That's a good way of putting it. So what I found is for, uh,
mail and calendar, I don't know if you do,
I don't know if the, what the outlet client for windows is like,
but for Mac it's not good. So I use,
and I'm pretty happy with just using the web web version of Outlook and calendar
and I'm, and I'm pretty happy with those. It's, you know,
it's not my favorite, but I'm making it work.
But here I am after six years of making fun of all your Microsoft crap.
And now I got to use it every day. Cause we all have to pay our penance.
I don't know what to do. It's,
it's you'll renormalize in, in no time.
I remember when I finally, when I finally gave up on the windows phone,
right? I'm like, no, I'm going to support our company.
And I finally gave up on windows phone and it took me maybe 15 minutes with the
app store on, on my, on my Samsung,
Android obviously. Uh, and I'm like, yeah,
that was a poor decision. Yeah. That was a poor decision.
Windows phone is a great story about Microsoft.
Windows phone was actually a really good phone. Uh,
the way it was set up, it was a good phone UI. It was a good phone.
Microsoft's ego got in their way.
That wasn't Microsoft's ego was bombers ego.
The bomber years were pretty devastating to, to,
to Microsoft. The, as a phone, the Microsoft phone was very, very,
it was actually really good.
The frustrating part of the windows phone was there were hardly any apps available
for, that's what makes phones is the apps. And not only that, but if,
I don't know if you recall this, but a lot of times when I shipped over to Android
and started re-installing my apps on Android, same apps, a lot of them,
plus some new ones, cause it had, you know, a hundred times as many, uh,
some of the apps that I'd use forever on windows phone and use on Android,
they actually had more features on Android. It's like, Oh my God,
what have I missing out on? And I've been using Apple phone now more.
I have Apple phone for work and an iPhone also called an iPhone. Yes.
And same as true as there, the,
the iPhone has maybe not as many apps in the long tail,
but there's a lot of apps that are iPhone only.
And some of the apps have more features in their Android counterparts.
I remember, I remember playing with Linux in the late nineties,
mid to late nineties at Microsoft and me saying out loud and getting laughed
at was Microsoft should make a windows 95 shell from Linux and they should have.
And I said the same thing with windows phone in the early 2000s,
we should write this shell to run on Android.
No, that ever happened because nobody listens to me and whatever,
but I honestly think imagine this. What if windows phone,
that shell ran on Android OS?
I think it'd be a very good phone. I think that I liked that tile approach,
but who knows? I don't know.
Yeah. No, the, uh, I don't see you said you have an iPhone or so on Android.
There's this component called the, the launcher. Are you familiar with that?
Yep.
It's kind of the thing that defines the sort of look and feel of the whole
thing. Well, there is this thing called the Microsoft launcher for Android.
And that is one of the top rated launchers for all of Android.
I don't currently use that's the,
that's the launcher I use just because of,
I really like how it organizes.
Yeah, that's interesting. My apps amongst everything else. Uh,
there is a launcher we, you could, you, and then maybe even this one,
I just may have forgotten it,
but there is a launcher where you can scan Android to look like the old windows
look. I believe it. Okay. Yeah. Oh well. I mean, but now it's for free.
Microsoft could have made some, could have done a little bit better.
I don't think it made money. They could have gained some customers.
There was a time I also said that, uh, Microsoft should stop. Here's,
here's the other suggestion I gave a little more out there. Take all the,
oh my God, I have so many stories about windows phone developers,
but the one thing I said, stop developing windows phone,
take all of those, whatever it was, like 400 developers working on it,
have them all right. Apps for Android and iOS will make more money that way
than them windows phone. I still think I would have been right,
but no. And I remember when I worked on Arcadia,
the stupid science project to make Android apps run on windows phone,
which is actually super easy.
I remember biting my tongue and sometimes laughing out loud when I'd be in a
meeting with these, these developers that worked on windows phone,
remember windows phone as far as I'm concerned was a complete nutter flop.
Uh, it was, I think we, I think if I recall,
not as much as Ken, which you've had stories on,
but I remember being in these meetings and those developers,
we, because a bunch of those folks moved over to this Arcadia team and those
developers were so,
this is the thing that Microsoft had I'll say had at the time,
maybe different now, bomber years. I think out of the bomber years,
it was expected that to get ahead,
you must have a very large ego and show it off daily.
I remember so many times those folks would say,
we try to make a decision. They say, well on windows phone, what we did,
and I'm thinking now I wanted to say out loud,
whatever you do on windows phone, whatever you did,
let's do the exact opposite. Let's everything you did.
Let's do the other thing and see if it sucks less.
You're like, thank you for your feedback.
I just facepalmed, rub my eyebrow off and, um,
waited for the drugs to kick in. Oh my God.
But you remember that ego. So here's, yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah.
And you can let me know what it was like in Microsoft now. And oh my gosh,
I get to work with Microsoft people now because of Azure and GitHub,
which is kind of Microsoft and other Microsoft things we use.
It's not kind of Microsoft. I know. Well,
it depends how the acquisition goes. Sometimes Microsoft, it depends.
Sometimes you leave stuff alone for longer. I mean,
is LinkedIn is Microsoft kind of, it's still pretty separate.
That's it's the windows organization is
still pretty set. Okay. Fine, fine, fine.
The point I wanted to bring up is other than those execs who happen to come from
Microsoft via Amazon, Unity was great.
There weren't egos getting in the way of good work. It was easy to do good work.
I noticed the same thing at NBCU. There aren't, Oh my God,
I have to tell you this as I hate that Steve listens to this podcast,
but I'll get over it because one great thing he did,
and I may have mentioned this before,
he set me up with like 30 people to go talk to.
You know how you always give the new hires people to go meet.
He gave me a massive list and 90% of the people,
no matter what their level were said, if you have any questions,
anything at all reach out anytime. We'll help you out. Imagine that.
Imagine me meeting a bunch of Microsoft execs back in the day,
maybe 10 years ago in that time. And how many of them would say that?
None. So that's the difference that I really, really like. I like working.
I mean, this isn't a hard, this is a little bit of a tautology, maybe.
I like working with people I like.
Yeah. I think you mean more than that though. I don't,
I don't miss that old model. I really don't, right? I kind of like,
I do like the fact that the more of the in point micro service service model,
the world that we're in right now has,
has almost killed the bet the farm mentality,
which bred these egotistical bastards who,
who would win arguments back in the old days when,
when no one had the data to dispute it, they would stand up.
I have been here for 15 years and they leverage BS background stories.
Yeah. Yeah.
I don't know.
Programming and cobalt or you were still waiting in the bed. I'm right.
You're wrong. Go back to school.
Yeah. And the thing is with, with the way the world functions now, yeah,
those people aren't really surviving as well as they used to.
Cause that wasn't the case. Remember when I left,
it was a weird place where Microsoft was growing up.
We had all these people that had been there 20 years or so just,
but who weren't,
who were still trying to do things the way they were 20 years ago.
And the one of my, that was one of my frustrations.
Yeah. And, and rightly so.
And I won't,
I won't look you in the eyes until you they're all gone. Right. Um,
the ones I've been paying attention to, I'll tell you,
there's only two of them left. It used to be like 20 and,
and right now the ones I'm paying attention to,
there's only two left because I will not mention names.
What are their initials? F U Frank.
All right. Okay. So you won't tell me, um, culture's getting better.
Culture is good here. I like working with people. I like, uh,
have we talked about anything at all substantial yet?
Uh, we briefly talked about chat GPT.
I repeat my question. Yeah.
We, we, we talked about forced office
attendance. All right. Okay. That's a bad thing. Um,
and I do think, right. So,
so the thing is like you, you, uh,
the in-person and personal connections are difficult to
quantify, but invaluable.
Let me just maybe set up and discuss a little bit. Um,
I'm going to talk about where I'm at and what I'm doing.
I think it may set up some different discussions.
So those of you that have been listening to the podcast for a very, very,
very long time, know that when I first joined unity,
we would spend some chunk of time in the podcast. I would talk about, again,
this podcast is just two guys talking over beer,
although I'm drinking water and Brent's picking his nose and just talking about
what's going on in front of people.
That's the whole premise of the podcast in the first place. We don't,
we have vague agendas, but six years ago at unity,
we talked about what was going on in the team, what I was thinking,
what I was learning, what the metaphors I was seeing,
the cool stuff I was discovering.
I think we can do a little bit of that here while I figure stuff out.
So one cool thing that happened,
I did not have direct reports up until this week.
So I spent my first month or so without direct reports.
Well,
I met a bunch of people and figured everything out and learned the projects and,
but at this point I have a team. I know what work needs to get done.
Not going to go details aren't important. When you work on stuff, I, you could,
it's, if you work on an infrastructure or a platform group,
it's the stuff you imagine it's things around cloud optimization and migrations
from tool X to tool Y. That's what we do. Very, very, very high level.
So I'm at the stage now where it's, which I really, really like.
It's working with a team to teach them, not teach them,
working with a team to help them learn how to deliver more consistently.
And you and I have talked about this a lot.
This lines up well with the modern testing principles,
which, uh, as an aside that I don't want to get into,
but it's a long story, but, uh,
our buddy James Bach added a bunch of comments to different articles on a website.
That's about this to launch officially at soft launched about to launch next week.
There'll be a blurb on various social media from me,
but he replied about modern testing principles. And guess what he said, not,
not my post, somebody else went, another one of the three posted them and he
said, Hey, these aren't modern. These aren't about testing at all.
We should call these modern delivery principles. Yes. Yes, we should.
But, uh, I read
me toad. All right. Well, call, I, I,
I kind of agree because it prompts the discussion.
So welcome to the discussion, James. I think in one of those replies,
he actually makes the point that I saw him made somewhere else,
saw him make somewhere else, which I couldn't find last week,
which is that he cares about testing and not quality.
And that's fine. He can do that. So anyway,
we're going to learn modern testing principles, modern delivery principles,
which is let's figure out, I mean, it's really agile and lean.
How can we deliver? How can we be transparent about the way we deliver?
How can we be accountable?
How can we begin to build up safety in our organization? How,
and then going back a topic or two,
how can we work effectively together,
even though none of us are together and it'll take time.
I think that safety part, especially it's going to take months.
You never get to a point where you go, yes, I've flipped the switch.
This team is now psychologically safe.
It is a spectrum that all you can do is try and move forward on all the time.
So we'll work on that. The normal stuff.
I'm trying to get the team in place to execute, uh, just made,
just had someone accept an offer for a director reporting to me,
working in the tool space. I'm excited about that.
We'll get them ramped up when they start. So just in the forming stage,
I guess. So it's fun and a lot of work to do a lot of just a lot of people to learn.
And you know, which is hard because as all three listeners know,
I don't really like people, but I like it when people are successful.
So I sacrifice my dislike of people to help people be successful.
And that's kind of where we're at now,
but we should probably some things we should dive into at some point,
but Brett, you haven't changed jobs in a long time.
What do you think about all that? What do you think about like diving into the,
Oh God, I have to do five projects. I'd never thought about before with,
with a huge number of people I've never thought about before.
How do you feel about that?
So I am doing the former all of the time. That's, I thought about it.
You're right. The,
I am now in the job that I have been in for the
longest continuous period in my entire career. So new,
new people, new people, new team that actually might be nice.
So I've been on the team now for the longest I have in my entire
career, eight years, right?
Previous to that I was in exchange for five and then up until then really a max
of three, right? I kind of, I, I found it more,
I kind of viewed myself more like Mary Poppins. All right.
I kind of solve this team or the, what I can hear is time to go to someplace else.
But in this, in the team I'm on right now,
we are changing direction as a, as a, um,
all the time as a data scientist, right?
My job is to, to answer the, the,
the questions the business has now.
So I'm constantly having to adapt.
And unfortunately sometimes it ends up being an interrupt,
which I'm trying to remove because that has a negative consequence on the,
on my team itself. But we're,
we're constantly doing new new new projects. And, and as I mentioned at the
start of the podcast, right?
GPT is representing a non trivial threat to a set of services that my team has
done for a long time. And so it's always exciting. Like I,
I called it a threat, but that's,
that's not the perspective I'm taking. Anytime change happens,
there's always opportunity. You need to look for it,
which is what I'm doing. And I'm starting to converge on it and starting to get,
um, other attention, which will,
which will result in new interesting work.
So I'm curious cause I, I, I,
I don't know if you give a good answer. It wasn't really the question I asked.
Okay. I mean, you kind of justify, you do what you do. It has some overlap.
I think it's worth calling out and my, um, my,
my boss sometimes asks me if I'm ready to run away screaming and I sometimes
feel, but not really feel like it. A role like this is as I've talked to some
other folks about it is kind of not for the faint of heart.
Brand new team, lots of stuff to, a lot of things to do,
a lot of legacy to move past,
a lot of things to learn. It's kind of a role. I love,
I love to start from scratch, but I don't think that everyone does.
No. So I have never been afraid.
It's quite the opposite. A lot of people were like, when I,
when I become the head of a new team,
I love it internally. I love it.
When one of my leaders comes to me and says,
Brandon, I hear what you're saying, but that won't work here. I love it.
I'm like, Oh yeah. You, you, you remember that you said that.
I'm a change agent and that,
that type of world is where change agents are like, okay,
there's a team that starts to change.
Have you ever done like a puzzle hunt or one of those kinds of things or even a
puzzle room where you, you know, there's a way out and actually you're,
and you're pretty confident because you've done one before maybe that you can
get out.
You don't know where to start and like my blog posts from a few weeks ago on
angry weasel.substack.com. You just start,
you find something,
you look at it and you figure out if it's a clue or not.
And maybe you come back to it later,
but that's kind of the organizational challenge. You look at things,
you trust, but verify you question,
you figure out if the smoke alarm was actually a fire and you just kind of poke
around till you make progress. And again, in a puzzle room,
you may be stuck. You may think you're stuck,
but you look back into the progress.
You'll, we must be getting somewhere.
You know,
we must be getting somewhere because I can see tangible progress I've made on
figuring stuff out. I just need to make a few more connections and I'll get into
the next room and start over again. I just made up this metaphor on the spot,
but I think it kind of works. And I like that.
I like not knowing where to start, but knowing,
but feeling at least semi confident that I can get to the end state and then
make a new,
to the end state and then make a new and then make a new end state,
but get to the end state. If I just begin and move forward.
The thing that I think is awesome about fresh eyes and right in this case,
your fresh eyes and your leadership, right? The thing,
old eyes,
the thing that's awesome about fresh eyes is you have not yet learned what can't
be done. Correct. It's all in front of me. And then the,
the combined that with a team that has learned what can't be done.
But if you remember way back in the, the 12 monkey story, not the,
the movie, but the one with the ladder where,
where there's a cultural thing set up and people are doing things that they
don't even remember why they're doing it that way anymore.
They just know it can't be done. They don't know why.
That's where someone with fresh eyes can can go, well, why are we doing this?
We don't know. Well, then let's just stop.
That is one of the reasons why I'm just, I think I told you,
I told you on this on the, on the podcast before,
like there was a team I was on years ago. It reminds me of this.
There was a team was on, I joined the team.
This was in the old school and they had shipped three products and had had their
build verification tests pass in six years.
And I'm like, what a bizarre problem. I was excited.
I went to my manager. I'm like,
I would absolutely love this problem because build verification tests are so
simple.
I'm kind of puzzled as to what your team,
what this team did to even make that possible. Right?
Yeah. I'd be, I'd be intentionally curious also. Yeah.
It's really hard to do this. I'm convinced of that.
It is much easier to get BBTs to pass them to go six years and have them not
pass. I would think so. So yeah. All right. Um,
let's call that a day, man. Cause I gotta go.
I do too. All right. Well, once again, I am.
Brant Jansen. No, I'm not. I'm, I'm Alan. I'm Brent.
Now we got it straight. Yeah, whatever. It's me. I'm the old age. All right.
See you man. It's like next week. Bye everybody. Thanks for listening. Bye.